[Musik]
Olaf Scholz will das Deutschland in
Europa eine Führungsrolle einnimmt das
ist sein Anspruch Deutschland strebe
danach ein Garant europäischer
Sicherheit zu werden so wie es unsere
Verbündeten von uns erwarten doch der
Praxistest fällt anders aus kein
Alleingang war bislang Scholz Mantra bei
der Lieferung vom Kampfpanzer Leopard in
die Ukraine doch inzwischen steht er im
Abseits europäische Partner trauen sich
er zögert
so will der britische Premier sunak die
Ukraine stärker unterstützen
einschließlich der Bereitstellung von
Challenger zwei Panzern der polnische
Präsident duda prescht ebenfalls vor wir
werden eine Kompanie von Leopard Panzern
im Rahmen einer Koalition übergeben die
sich derzeit bildet
Zusage auch vom finnischen Präsidenten
Minister bei einem europäischen Vorgehen
wird auch ein Beitrag Finnlands benötigt
der Eindruck von außen der entsteht ist
immer dass Deutschland gedrängt wird
etwas zu tun und eben nicht freiwillig
den nächsten Schritt geht und das immer
erst dann macht wenn sich andere auch
bewegt haben und eben nicht sich eine
Spitze einer Bewegung setzt und andere
Staaten mitnimmt so war es auch bei der
Entscheidung Schützenpanzer Marder der
Ukraine zu liefern nur auf Druck der
Verbündeten handelt Scholz als der Druck
zu groß wurde Deutschland als
getriebener denn als autark agierende
Akteur das entspricht leider nicht dem
selbstgenannten Führungsanspruch der
Bundesregierung hier scheitert die
Regierung Scholz und das ist hoch bitter
weil das Vertrauen in die Bundesrepublik
zunehmend singt das Vertrauen in die
Bundesrepublik als politische und
wirtschaftliche leitnation Europas aber
auch in die deutsche Rüstungsindustrie
Scholz nimmt Rücksicht auf seine
Fraktion die Sorge vor einer Eskalation
ist hier groß ein Strategiepapier
fordert Verhandlungen mit Russland
erwähnt Panzer mit keinem Wort von hier
Lob für den Kanzler ich nehme den
Bundeskanzler in seiner Kanzlerschaft
nie als zögerlich war er ist besonnen
erwägt ab ein ehemaliger Abgeordneter
der der Fraktion wegen eines zu
linkspazifistischen Kurses in der
Verteidigungspolitik den Rücken gekehrt
hat erklärt das ist eben doch eine
Partei die in der Vergangenheit sich
wenig mit dem Vorstellungen beschäftigt
hat das Frieden und Sicherheit in Europa
auch mit militärischer Gewalt verteidigt
werden müssen und dass man dazu eigene
Maßnahmen ergreifen muss von deutscher
Seite und das ist das Thema dass die SPD
beschäftigt da bewegt sie sich zum Teil
noch etwas tastend Anerkennung für den
zögernden panzerkurs des Kanzlers auch
von eher ungewohnter Seite
man sieht ja aktuell gerade in dieser
Situation dass der Bundeskanzler genau
abwägt inwieweit sich Deutschland immer
weiter in diesen Krieg mit hinein
manövriert und ich denke das ist richtig
seine Haltung deswegen muss er
standhalten und sich hier klar auch
durchsetzen gegenüber seinen
Koalitionspartnern den Grünen und der
FDP die hier immer weiter
Kriegstreiberei betreiben
Ungeduld bei FDP und Grünen der grüne
Abgeordnete Robin Wagner initiierte
einen Aufruf im Verbund sollen die
Europäer den Leopard Richtung Ukraine
schicken und Deutschland müsse diesen
Verbund anführen wir haben die
deutlichen Forderungen unserer
Freundinnen und Freunde das Deutschland
eine Führungsrolle einnehmen soll eine
solche Führungsrolle kann man aber auch
nicht als Schlusslicht einnehmen das
heißt wir müssen jetzt auch mutig
vorangehen in dieser Koalition und
selber einbringen mit unseren eigenen
Panzern
Unruhe in der Ampel Irritation im
Ausland doch am Ende der letzten Woche
ein Kanzler der sich nicht beirren
lassen will er wird nicht dazu kommen
dass in Deutschland aufgeregte
Stellungnahmen schnelle Äußerungen die
Notwendigkeit alle zehn Minuten etwas
sagen zu müssen dazu führt dass wir über
so ernste Dinge die mit Krieg und
Frieden zusammenhängen und mit der
Sicherheit unseres Landes der Sicherheit
Europas einfach mal so aus der Hand
schütteln doch die Partner sie schauen
auf Berlin auf einen Kanzler der sich
entscheiden muss wer folgt auf
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht wer
vertritt Deutschland beim Treffen der
Verbündeten in Ramstein und liefert
Deutschland Kampfpanzer oder nicht
und bei mir hier im Studio begrüße ich
jetzt den SPD-Vorsitzenden schönen guten
Abend Herr Klingbeil schönen guten Abend
Herr klingt mal wir können jetzt nicht
über die verteidigungs- und
Sicherheitspolitik sprechen ohne über
die Verteidigungsministerin zu reden
deren Rücktritt hier im Raum steht sie
sind der erste aus der SPD-Spitze den
wir fragen können in den letzten Tagen
was wird denn nun aus Frau Lambrecht ich
habe Zeitungsartikel gelesen wie Sie
wahrscheinlich auch aber wissen Sie ich
habe mir irgendwann mal angewöhnt diese
Artikel nicht zu kommentieren und das
gilt auch heute Abend das ist ja eine
wichtige Personalie und wenn sich da
etwas bewegt dann haben sie als SPD
Parteivorsitzender das Recht eine
Nachfolger oder eine Nachfolgerin zu
benennen wollen sie sagen dass Frau
Lamprecht sie nicht informiert hat also
ich kann erstmal nur sagen wir haben
eine Verteidigungsministerin die mit
Hochdruck an ihren Aufgaben arbeitet
wenn wir auf die letzte Woche schauen
Frau Lambrecht war in Schwerin unterwegs
hat das Marina Arsenale eröffnet hat
sich jetzt am Freitag noch mal um den
Puma Panzer gekümmert also wirklich eine
Ministerin die anpackt und ich habe
gerade gesagt ich kommentiere
Zeitungsartikel nicht aber in einer
Sache können Sie im Grundsatz ausgehen
das was wir als SPD zu entscheiden haben
das entscheiden wir geschlossen mit dem
Bundeskanzler zusammen mit der
Parteiführung mit dem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden und wir verkünden
Dinge dann wenn sie zu verkünden sind
aber das gilt im Grundsatz und nicht im
spezifischen hier das durch die
Informationen allerdings Unruhe
entstanden ist das haben sie ja auch
mitbekommen jetzt ist die Frage was
machen Sie denn konkret in der nächsten
Woche steht die das Treffen der Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe in Ramstein an da stehen
viele viele Entscheidungen an die von
der Verteidigungsministerin mit
diskutiert und getragen werden müssen
kann sich die Bundesregierung ist
leisten dort eine Frau hinzuschicken von
der eigentlich alle glauben sie ist mit
einem Bein schon raus aus dem Job also
das teile ich überhaupt nicht christine
lumprecht hat große Rückendeckung ich
habe gerade gesagt wie sie in den
letzten Tagen noch unterwegs also die
wichtig ist auf den Weg gebracht hat und
wissen sie es geht doch hier insgesamt
um die Bundesregierung es geht um die
Frage wie positioniert sich Deutschland
und ich bin mir sicher diese Rammstein
Konferenz in den nächsten Wochen wird
ein deutliches Signal setzen die
Bündnispartner stehen an der Seite der
Ukraine wir haben seit dem 24 Februar
jetzt wahnsinnig viel getan um die
Ukraine zu unterstützen wir sehen die
Erfolge auch die die Ukraine hat und
dieser Kurs wird uneingeschränkt
weitergehen ich muss sie noch einmal zur
Frau Lamprecht befragen und nerven damit
wie schnell wollen Sie denn die
Unklarheit jetzt beseitigen wann haben
wir Klarheit übertragen gerade gesagt
ich kommentiere keine Zeitungsartikel
und Sie können jetzt über den dritten
oder vierten Weg fragen und meine
Aussage dazu wird sich nicht ändern egal
wer den Job dann in der kommenden Woche
macht die Zwickmühle für Olaf Scholz die
wir eben im Beitrag auch gesehen haben
die bleibt ja auf der einen Seite die
europäischen Verbündeten die eine
Führungsrolle fordern und auf der
anderen Seite die SPD die den Kanzler
für seine Besonnenheit lobt was gilt
denn nun eigentlich vorangehen oder
hinterherlaufen ja da werden immer
wieder Sprüche in der öffentlichen
Debatte aufgemacht die ich gar nicht
sehe wissen Sie die Partei die Fraktion
wir stützen den Kanzler seit dem 24
Februar all diesen Fragen Deutschland
ist Riesenschritte gegangen wir haben
mit einem Prinzip wir brauchen keine
Waffen mehr in kriegs- und Krisengebiete
zu liefern Deutschland ist heute der
zweite oder drittgrößte Waffenlieferant
wir haben gerade in der letzten Woche
eine international abgestimmte mit Joe
Biden mit dem wichtigsten Bündnispartner
mit den Amerikanern verkündete
Entscheidung jetzt dass wir
Schützenpanzer liefern das ist schweres
Gerät und das zeigt doch wie diese
Bundesregierung wie dieser Kanzler aber
auch die Koalition und alle Parteien die
sie tragen an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen aber ich halte das für richtig
dass wir Politik nicht so machen dass
wir Prozesse beschreiben dass wir
einzelvorschläge haben dass wir national
Alleingänge haben sondern das klare
Signal an putin ist doch sich
international abzustimmen und es macht
was wenn der amerikanische Präsident und
der deutsche Bundeskanzler gemeinsam die
nächsten Schritt verkünden Rolf Mütze
nicht hat in der letzten Woche sehr klar
noch mal gesagt es gibt keine rote
Linien und dahinter stehe ich zu 100 %
Besonderheit ist die eine Sache die
aktuellen Debatten und Gegebenheiten in
der Ukraine die andere wir können sehen
wohin Zurückhaltung führt wenn man sich
jetzt die Diskussion über den Leopard
Panzer anschaut in der Bild am Sonntag
gab es heute ein Interview mit dem Chef
des rüstungsunternehmens Rheinmetall der
die Leopard Panzer auf dem Hof stehen
hat sozusagen der sagt selbst wenn die
Bundesregierung heute bestellen würde
wären die Leopard Panzer frühestens 2024
einsatzfähig nicht schnell zu
entscheiden und nur besonnen vorzugehen
hat also erhebliche Konsequenzen können
sie sich das leisten aber entschuldigung
das ist doch keine
Konsequenz dieses Bundeskanzlers oder
dieser Bundesregierung dass wir eine
Armee haben dass wir eine Armee haben
die nicht gut ausgestattet ist das ist
eine Konsequenz aus 16 Jahren Union im
Verteidigungsministerium und es ist die
Wände die jetzt mit diesem Bundeskanzler
gekommen ist dass wir 100 Milliarden in
die Hand nehmen dass wir die Bundeswehr
ausstatten dass wir dafür sorgen dass
neues Gerät bestellt wird aber wer immer
glaubt man muss irgendwo nur die Garage
aufmachen oder beim bestellten montags
und Freitag das ist das da der muss sich
bitte intensiver mit Rüstungsindustrie
auseinandersetzen das dauert aber diese
Regierung dieser Bundeskanzler führen
gerade die Kehrtwende die zeitenwände
bei der Bundeswehr ein das wird die
Bundeswehr stark machen aber wir können
nur Dinge liefern die auch da sind genau
kurzfristige Lieferung geht nicht hat
der rheinmetallchef gesagt von denen
könnte man die Leopard Panzer holen
morgen wird es konkret Polens Staatschef
ist zu Besuch beim Kanzler und kommt
wieder mit der Forderung mehr Leopard
Panzer bzw überhaupt Leopard Panzer zu
liefern in die Ukraine er steht damit
nicht alleine in Europa warum wartet
Scholz ab und überlässt es anderen
Ländern die neue Sicherheitspolitik zu
formulieren und vorzugeben nochmal Olaf
Scholz hat wahnsinnig viel mit dieser
Regierung seit dem 24 Februar getan aber
er hat ein politischen Stil der bedeutet
ich spreche mich intern ab und dann
verkündigt Dinge nicht andersrum und das
halte ich ja so richtig dass man das in
einer großen Frage von Krieg und Frieden
genauso macht es gibt viele Menschen in
diesem Land die sind verunsichert die
wollen klug geführt werden und die
wollen keine Politiker die täglich
einfach immer eine neue Überschriften
produzieren sagt der
SPD-Parteivorsitzende herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch sehr gerne